what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future okay
it's so a lot of you guys have been
asking what's the identity of the Red
Hulk because a lot of the guys were like
I thought I knew what the identity was
but then the whole reveal like that
whole conflict changed what I thought
the identity was nothing makes any sense
who is the Red Hulk well in this video
we're gonna find out also to correct a
couple of questions people had from the
last talk video we did not everything
was a hallucination in the mind of
banner everything up to the Incredible
Hulk slice all the heroes being turned
into Hulk's that's all real the only
thing that was a hallucination and the
mind of banner was when he woke up and
he was with Betty Ross it was at some
point between when all the heroes were
irradiated with gamma energy and turned
into Hulk's to the point that we saw
that their banner was hooked up to the
machine and of course he had this whole
illusion with Betty Ross so everything
else like everything that's happened so
far has actually happened
that's all in Marvel's continuity it's
all official stuff so I want to go ahead
and throw that out there because I saw a
lot of people who are coming to the
conclusion that everything so far was a
hallucination that's not the case all
this stuff is actually real so what we
do here is we basically pick up again
with this golden Helicarrier and it's
really just kind of following up
immediately after all these events that
taking place now keep in mind the
Intelligencia have the ape smartest
people have hooked up to this machine
and again their overall goal is to draw
all the intelligence from these
individuals essentially make them dumb
and then use that intelligence for their
own purposes the other half of this is
that while this is happening in the
intelligence you are drawing out this
intelligence we're basically dealing
with these irradiated hoaxes fighting
each other now the cool thing about this
is we actually get this really badass
image of Hulk Thor against the Red Hulk
and it's actually really really cool to
see because all about you guys but Thor
Hulk looks badass
like he looks so beast and I really want
to see him come back I really want to
see that happen again the funny thing
about this though and this is something
to keep in mind these guys are
transformed into Hulk's but it was a
sudden process and they haven't really
been graduated into it it was not an
organic change and so essentially what
happened is they had extreme strength
but they kind of lost their intelligence
with it now exactly how it is that Jeff
lobe and Greg patch square that circle
is not really explained here because
what they're essentially saying is that
when a person has turned into an
Incredible Hulk their intelligence is
reduced to the point where it's you know
infantile and all they have is just
brute strength they can't really form
coherent sentences they just kind of
speak ad hoc you know like I want this I
do this you know things like that they
just can't speak very clearly or
intelligently they basically speak the
exact same way that the Incredible Hulk
does now the other half of this equation
is to more or less make the assumption
that inside these hooks somewhere is
Thor you know inside Thor Hulk is
actually Odin's son himself and so much
like how Bruce Banner turns into the
Incredible Hulk Thor has turned into
Thor Hulk the difference is that they
don't have the ability to turn back
again or at least out of their own
volition anyway and of course again
we'll see things go back to normal here
but the funny thing about this is again
Red Hulk is wildly intelligent in terms
of his military strategy he's not
science intelligent he strategically
intelligent and because of this he
basically has the Hawks start working
against each other he goes to Captain
America he says hey look are you really
gonna let four get all the glory here
you gonna let four be the one to beat me
and of course Captain America substance
is enough I'm gonna be the one to do it
well then Carol Danvers steps in and
says no I'm gonna be the one to do it so
they basically start fighting each other
now again what this does is really give
Red Hulk an out that's really what Jeff
lobe and Greg Pak were doing they were
saying we need to create a situation
where we can reveal the identity of Red
Hulk none of these guys are gonna be the
ones to figure it out we need to give
him a way to effectively slink away from
this fight now even in the Red Hawks
mine himself he sees himself acting very
cowardly in the sense that he's just
kind of like you know I'm taking the
coward's way out I really feel like I
should be the one fighting here but what
he says is there's a time to stay and
there's a time to run it's that classic
art of war by Sun Tzu if you're fighting
an enemy and the enemy is more capable
on their terrain then drag them to your
terrain make them fight on your soil as
opposed to fighting on their soil the
goal should be to always give yourself
the advantage now the other half of this
is we actually find out there's trouble
in paradise here again where doc
Samson's cthe axis machine was basically
the reason why it is that the
intelligence you were able to transfer
gamma energy from Bruce Banner and then
irradiated the other hooks doc Samson's
like this is not how things were
supposed to be this is not how they were
supposed to go not all these guys were
supposed to be irradiated
now Red Hulk of course makes his way
over to our banners located at because
rumor he's still hooked up to this
machine and even red hook himself
comments this is not how things were
supposed to be and so what the
indication seems to be here
is that the intelligence he effectively
duped everyone yes Red Hulk was supposed
to serve the purpose of capturing Bruce
Banner bringing him in as The Incredible
Hulk and allowing the Intelligencia to
use the Incredible Hulk to gamma
radiation notice who irradiated soldiers
and turned them into your book top
military guys but Red Hulk basically
went rogue he went off the reservation
and he more or less beep Howard Bruce
Banner so yeah he threw a wrench in the
works when it came to what the
intelligence Hijaz original plan was but
it seems like the intelligence he had
always intended to do this they had
always intended to basically betray Red
Hulk and betray dr. Samson in the
process and so of course we're
spider-man Hulk hitch comes into the
fray along with will rain hope again
this is really just kind of different
roadblocks coming up in the path of Red
Hulk but ultimately what this does is
allow for the reveal of his identity and
the reason why is because he does not
have unlimited strength again that's one
of the big caveats of the Red Hulk his
strength is not limitless instead he
gets hotter the angrier he gets and so
because of the fact that it strains to
not limitless he's basically wearing
himself down to the point that red
she-hulk can make her appearance so the
two of them essentially just start
fighting one another they really just
kind of start battling one another the
funny thing about this is that red hope
begins to offer this explanation you
know begins to have this conversation
I guess this inner monologue as he's
fighting against red she-hulk and what
he says is you know he almost felt like
he knew exactly who she was even though
she didn't really reveal her identity to
a made against him years maybe it was
something in her eyes maybe it was her
personality maybe was how abrasive she
was but for whatever reason he saw
himself in her but he wasn't 100% sure
of what her identity was until she
seized him and tried to kill him and
when he said go ahead and kill me if you
really want to kill me then go ahead and
kill me because I'm a fraction of who I
was before I'm a coward I'm a wimp I ran
away from a fight I have to ally myself
with Bruce Banner my immortal enemy and
this is when we learned that the
identity of Red Hulk is in fact general
Thunderbolt Ross
so for those of you guys who are
wondering how it is that Red Hulk killed
Thunderbolt Ross when Red Hulk is
Thunderbolt Ross we will find out more
about that later on not only that we
also learned that the identity of Red
Sea Hawk is Betty Ross is his daughter
Betty Ross when this first happened I
know by now this is old hat this is old
news I'm sure people who were reading
The Incredible Hulk run beforehand we're
like
man we knew that like this isn't new
like this is stuff that we've known the
entire time I'm sure people were just
like yeah you know whatever but for
people who didn't know for those of you
guys who've never read an incredible
hoax story in your life who never had a
reason to go look at any Wikipedia
articles or any spoilers no were
literally just waiting on me to tell you
the excitement that you're feeling right
now
is the same excitement that we had
before because we were just like I mean
I always thought it was general
Thunderbolt Ross and then he gets killed
by Red Hawk who the hell is Red Hawk so
it was a really well played drawn-out
event it was really well played the way
was done over the course of this you
know cuz I think by this point we're
about a year and a half and to the
writing of Jeph Loeb and Greg Pak under
their Incredible Hulk run I'm pretty
sure like the you know world where
Hawkes was kind of them finishing it out
and then that transition into the return
of the Incredible Hulk I think it was
but from here we switch over to Bruce
Banner now again Bruce Banner is still
hooked up to the Machine of the
Intelligencia and so his intelligence is
slowly being drained away and so keep in
mind everything we're gonna be seeing
here really right up until the very end
is all an illusion none of this stuff is
real with the exception of something
that I'll point out here in a second but
something to note here this is actually
really really cool something to note
here is it's not like the intelligencia
put Bruce banners mind through absolute
torture and made him endure the worst
moments of its life now there's a reason
for this the reason why is because
whenever it comes to systems where the
mind is effectively tricked and this is
actually a really really huge talking
point when it came to Doctor Doom during
Jonathan Hickman's
run of Fantastic Four one of the big
issues here is that if they were to
subject Bruce banners mind to I guess
you know ultimate violence he may reject
what's going on
he may say no no no I refuse to relive
these and he could transform into the
Hulk without meaning to because keep in
mind the Hulk is still inside of Bruce
Banner it's just for whatever reason
he's not able to access it that really
seems to be the indication as it was
pulled from Red Hulk that Bruce Banner
was just really kind of reduced out of
his normal self and it didn't seem like
the Hulk was going to come back what
this was was the intelligence here
really just hedging their bets they said
okay look what we want is the
intelligence of Bruce Banner how we get
it doesn't matter we could turn around
and we could subject him to the worst
case scenario in terms of his own
psychological experiences but what we're
going to do is we're going to give him a
great psychological experience the
reason is because he won't want to leave
he'll want to stay there
the more
wants to stay there the longer he will
stay there and the easier it'll be to
extract his intelligence so the life he
gets is a utopia I mean he's got you
know general Thunderbolt Ross he's got a
strong relation with with his
father-in-law
you know his marriage to Betty Ross is
amazing they've got two kids of their
own I mean this is the perfect life for
a Bruce Banner to the point that he
doesn't want to let it go I mean you
know he is a major pioneer of the
scientific industry of course the
leaders kind of running the show or at
least the leader is someone they look up
to but in the end the one desire of
Bruce Banner has come to fruition in the
sense that the Incredible Hulk is no
longer a part of his life and the reason
being because Bruce Banner killed the
Incredible Hulk now we're not really
shown how he did it you know with the
exception of a rocket through the chest
but that's about it but again one of the
other kickers here is that the
Incredible Hulk and Bruce Banner are
depicted as two distinctly different
beings now the reason why this matters
is because this is Greg Pak drawing back
to the onslaught saga it wasn't the
biggest thing in the history of the
world but when the entity when the
psyche entity onslaught which is to say
the combination of xavier z' frustration
with humanity and Magneto's hatred for
humanity when those two things merged
into a singular being an onslaught
literally just started wrecking through
the entire superhero community the only
way they were really able to crack his
armor so to speak and do any real damage
was for Jean Grey to split the mind of
the Incredible Hulk and Bruce Banner
into two separate beings so that the
Incredible Hulk could just be unbridled
raged without any kind of subconscious
control from Bruce Banner and so because
of this the Incredible Hulk was about as
strong as he'd ever been up until his
world break her form but when he went to
go punch onslaught he cracked his armor
in the process and so because of this it
allowed the heroes to basically try to
dissipate onslaught or try to kill him
which of course led into the heroes
reborn storyline when Franklin Richards
created a new universe all that kind of
crazy stuff but again this is really
just an instance whereby the writers of
the story Jeph Loeb and Greg Pak are
grabbing some of the oldest incredible
whole content you know all the way back
to Peter David even before when we
talked about Joe fix-it as well as
including you know some contemporary
some modern stuff with some of his most
iconic incidents or most iconic roles in
the Marvel Universe but again the other
half of this is that we're dealing with
at least on the outside we're dealing
with all these different Hawks now of
course you have like the Avengers Hawks
that are fighting against Red Hulk and
so on and so forth remember that's
what's happening right now in this
particular moment as this
story goes on we also have the other
Hawks the superhero Hawks who are going
against Red Hulk and so on and so forth
and so back on earth you know back in
the normal world we have of course a
Bhamra challenge and we have Korg again
another member of the incredible Hawks
warbound doing what they can to fend off
these irradiated soldiers who are all
basically Hawks now could try as they
might a bomb and cord just aren't really
able to pull this off on their own and
now scar is able to help and he actually
has a pretty huge impact here in a
little while but one of the funny things
we're gonna find here is that none of
these guys are a match for the
overwhelming odds they're facing the
only person who can really stand against
them is the Incredible Hulk and what
this was was Jeff lobe and Greg Pak
setting the stage saying Bruce Banner
has to come back The Incredible Hulk has
to come back not because he wants to but
because he has to because if he doesn't
the world will become Hulk's and the
intelligence Hijaz will win and so it's
literally the incredible hope being
transformed into a one-man army and when
the Incredible Hulk comes back oh my god
when the incredible hook comes back dude
it is a sight to behold it's one of the
coolest things it's dude it's it's it's
you could see it like a scene from a
movie like if we'll get to that in the
next video it's bad ass oh my god it's
so cool anyway I can't wait for that so
anyway back in Bruce banners you know in
his mind again the you know that's the
state reality he's actually visited by
Doctor Doom now this is really really
cool because what it tells us what Greg
Pak and Jeff Lowe tell us is that yes
this is an illusion
yes you know these different members
these are intelligent men who have been
taken by the intelligence yeah yes
they're all sharing in the same kind of
dreamscape but not everyone is on board
with this not only that it really shows
us just how smart Doctor Doom is now
this does not mean that dr. doom is
smarter than Reed Richards or anybody
else he is to a degree but again he and
Reed really alternate what it means is
that dr. doom was the one who was taken
just before Bruce Banner and so doom
hasn't really been converted entirely
yet instead he's still maintaining some
recollection of himself now when he sits
down and he talks to Bruce Banner he
says look Reed Richards T'Challa Hank
Pym these guys have all been taken Hank
Pym is like the least intelligent out of
all of us but he says these guys have
all been taken and because of this
full-on part of this system the way they
know that is because they're becoming
less and less intelligent because
they're doing long division now long
division is stupid long division is the
dumbest thing in the world give you a
hell yeah if you hate long division
Stone Cold Steve Austin I Love You Man
but it's just an indication it's
essentially dr. doom awakening Bruce
Banner to the realism of the situation
they're not the smartest men in this
whole place because they're effectively
getting dumber and dumber nobody says is
that the longer they stay here their
intelligence is effectively being
drained away by some giant organism in
the sky which is basically MODOK MODOK
is designed for the purpose of at least
in this dreamscape supplying energy to
the whole city making sure everybody has
everything they need but in reality this
is the machine that their intelligence
is being pulled into in order for the
intelligence yet to eventually grasp and
so because of the fact that dr. doom is
not as smart as he used to be because
he's not as intelligent as he used to be
he's not quite aware of the fact that he
basically has magic he's not quite aware
of the fact of what it was that he was
capable of and so what he does is he
sits down with Bruce Banner and says hey
look you need to take this gauntlet you
need to push the very fringes of this
reality you need to find a way to break
through and you need to wake up now
again this is significant because of the
fact that this is an instance where
Bruce Banner is again the only one who
can ever really save them now of course
as he's studying this particular
gauntlet the program that he's in begins
to kind of bring him back in with
remember he's basically walking towards
this doorway he's walking towards this
exit the program is designed to make
sure no one leaves and so it literally
drags him back by having his son
interrupt him in the middle of all this
now what this is is it's kind of like
this inception moment right you know in
the sense that in the movie Inception
the idea for the general public for the
average viewer who went to go see the
question was is Leonardo DiCaprio
dreaming or is he in the real world and
we saw the topspin and people were left
to try to figure out on their own but if
you caught the very last moment before
everything went to black that you would
know he's in the real world and so it's
kind of like Christopher Nolan's
comparison to this in the sense that it
is this scenario where even if he's not
in the real world Bruce Banner doesn't
care he has the perfect life he has
exactly what it is that he wants and
this is something that he actually says
to Doctor Doom Doctor Doom shows up on
his doorstep and says hey look you know
I know
and you want to stay here I know that
you love this life that you're in but
this is not the real world
this is not the world that you're
supposed to be in yes you know Bruce
Banner fixed the gauntlet yes he made it
work like it was supposed to
yes dr. doom was able to take the
gauntlet but banner doesn't want to use
it because if he does it means he's
going to wake up from the truth of this
reality and when he wakes up from the
truth of this reality he's gonna be
faced with the life that he doesn't want
and so what happens is doom says hey man
sorry about your luck you need to wake
up if you wake up that means that I can
wake up it means we can go back to the
life that we had before now doom does
have it his own alter your motives and
we'll find out what those are but in
order to force banner out of this dream
that he's having he basically grabs
banners son and he transforms him into
scar and the reason why he does is he
says look if your son will emerge as
scar basically you know if he'll come
back you know as this extremely powerful
being then he'll be able to destroy this
reality and if he's able to destroy it
well wake up simply because it would
cease to exist now this is a big gamble
the reason why is because their mind is
angered to this and so it's entirely
possible that if dr. doom had destroyed
this reality their minds just would have
been lost they would have gone straight
along with it a really good example of
this came during the vanos Quest
storyline I think it was when Thanos was
tracking down the Infinity stones anyone
against Grand Master and Grand Master
said I will give you my stone only under
the condition that you can defeat me in
a game and so what happened is they
don't ended up using an actual robot to
basically go against Grand Master but
when he went into the game he basically
destroyed the game inside of Grand
Master's Mon and so Graham answered with
the sense of just trapped inside of his
own body he was trapped inside of his
own mind that's entirely what could have
happened here the problem with this is
that as Betty Ross essentially steps in
and when Betty Ross is essentially able
to take out scarve effectively killing
Bruce banners son as he perceives him at
the same time in the real world dr. doom
yanked him out of his illusion and so we
basically have Bruce Banner back to
reality and this is where things go from
bad to worse and the reason for this is
we would think under normal
circumstances that Bruce Banner being
back to reality would work because it
would be all the other members of the
intelligence er waking up all the other
of members of the intelligence yeah
coming back to normal the problem with
this is that again you know the battle
between Skaar and all these guys that
scar red she holds the whole nine yards
the battle between all of them is
stretching into the holding cells of
where the inteligencia worked
keeping banner and doom and so on and so
forth and so once they get in there scar
without thinking without paying any
attention a tax red she-hulk
stabs her through the back and when he
does she essentially reverts back to her
normal human form which is revealed to
be Betty Ross and this is why I say The
Incredible Hulk is gonna come back
because Bruce Banner is looking at the
woman that he thought was dead because
in his dream world he had Betty Ross and
his mind you know it was possible she
was alive he didn't know where she was
he didn't know who she was he had no
idea what was going on with her all he
knew was that she was alive but in the
dream world he could hold her he could
touch her she was there and so it was
guaranteed in his mind and he didn't
want to let it go
in this real world Betty Ross is alive
you know and he's holding her in her
arms the problem is she's about to be
not alive but she's about to be dead and
so this is effectively what we're
getting ready to see is the return of
world breaker Hulk and this is why I say
gets real son because the
incredible book comes back in
spectacular fashion but if you guys are
new here to college explain if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and make sure you guys leave a
comment below we should hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob port
don't forget about that and yeah the
guys want to see some more Incredible
Hulk stuff I'm not gonna do it every day
I promise I'm not gonna bombard you guys
with ten incredible home videos in one
week don't worry
relax but uh if you guys want to see
more Incredible Hulk stuff he only to be
like every other day or twice a week or
something like that but leave a comment
and let me know and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]